allora cominciamo a girare sì però un
impegno importantissimo aveva non posso
proprio credere importantissimo torno
subito è ma una riunione tra iniziamo
così
la difesa non è tecnica zini è perché
non li trova
i blogs di oggi attaccato ha acceso
l'acqua per camuffare diciamo le tue
discussioni ci allontaniamo tranquillo
ora potrai discussi in santa pace
aqu vedo che hai assunto una nuova donna
delle pulizie ai ragazzi ogni volta che
bene di scegliere qua lei salva la
liberazione della mia cucina nel senso
che aspetta io sono molto bravo a fare
la cucina o accumula fumo lacuna cumula
cumulo e poi a un certo punto alcun
accumula cumulo di cocaina ha sgravato e
metto in ordine a malaga schifo a far
vedere dove la soluzione è momentanea
intanto mi riscaldo camente se questo
come ha regalato timberland probeat
agency caro guglielmo per te un capo con
imbottitura termica realizzando in pet
riciclato al 100 per cento delle
collezioni e respect match a di
timberland un abbraccio sylviane sangue
quindi grazie se di alessandro hanno
visto che io sono sempre in giro con una
giacca a vento grigia o rigide che stava
malissimo con qualsiasi cosa mentessi
volevo cambiare
quanto questo per me è il mio nuovo
giubbotto di sempre finché non mi verrà
regalato un altro giubbotto perché non
compro vestiti in questo modo se avete i
capelli sono la chascona poi si crea
perché la di nuovo a fit giubbotto direi
che sta riscrivendo la moda del 2020
bomber land cosa sto facendo mi immagino
facendo un biglietto di auguri e tiziana
city zanda una persona speciale
non vi dico chi è rilasciata con questo
esordio a questo grandissimo punto
interrogativo
in realtà una delle idee anche quello di
renderlo scaricabile se volete vuoi fare
gli auguri e quindi al posto di tiziana
dove c'è la letterina davanti a le
pudenda di babbo natale mettere il nome
della persona che volete e poi in realtà
non so se li vedete aspettate che biazzo
ci stiamo tutti quanti noi vestiti da
elfi questo gatto in realtà il bulbo
crea essere una renna qui sotto abbiamo
gianmarco che contro un tossico e non
pensavo di farlo ad averlo fatto così
simile a enrico ha la macchina
fotografica
tu hai le cuffie mentre ascolti gli
audio di vita buttata
qui c'è la linea che attaccata a una
candy che in gigante che sta facendo il
palo e qua sopra ci sono io con un
telefono in realtà tutti quanti avremo
una sorta di sano pet tac tac tac tac e
poi va belle le scarpette quelli linda
ed i cappelli di voglio fare tutti
quanti diversi ma devo capire da capire
per assecondare la personalità come
farli lavinia è abbastanza intuitiva
perché l'unica ragazza salopette la
gonnellina poi ovviamente calze lunghe e
anche lei le scarpe come riusciva a
letto affronta bellissimo le ginocchia
punta con le ginocchia appunto un ok poi
ci sono io mi farei l'out fit normale
cioè pantaloncini corti in classico è il
classico ma vuoi farti tipo do di bobby
sono già nella vita sto diversificando
enrico lo faccio enrico colavita
pantaloncini anche a lui corti una
bretella su è una bretella giu perché si
è dimenticato pure di vestirsi si è
dimenticato una scarpa a casa enrico
mettiamo questo così le maniche corte
anche a lui quindi in questo è simile a
me tutto quanto simile ha capito a suo
fratello che lui prende come spunto di
riferimento e lo guarda lo guarda il
cappuccio dietro e li metteremo un
cappuccio come se avesse una sorta di
cappuccio esattamente il cappello con la
visiera che carino a te 1 giu cottino mi
metto il classico cappellino da elfo
semplice del quello di arrigo supermosse
il tuo zuccotto il mio è così è la linea
alla linea lo mettiamo piccolino
trattamento non ha conosciuto i piccoli
grazie a un più avanti viene rasa perché
si vede il cosciotto di pollo del più
ripiene rammarico c'è le cose più larghi
del vietnam e convince sta sta roba da
quando è detto non ti convince
sentite qua vi ho già aver che cazzo
sottile cioè tu cosa faresti
era molto più carino si vuole è notevole
anche se fatto molto male però capitola
sente invece fatto bella io preferisco
quello e non ho mai usato io questo caso
mai usato in vita mia è stata una mano
come disegnare sono più comodo ma darò
una recensione che la prima volta deluso
è completamente diversa da una matita e
come imparare a camminare si disegna una
cosa che forse per capire più facilmente
però giro tranquilla vedere lo sai che
mi ricorda con la di scooby doo casa che
mi ricorda stupido se più proporzionata
nel senso che se no dovrebbe essere così
un po meno di come lo chiede cancellarlo
[Risate]
troppo grosso da imi la cia stonature o
quando il re si mette a parigi zoom e mi
porge basta
ma no ma no ma sta facendo vedere a
gianmarco come i ragazzi ci sta un tempo
assurdo e la cosa bella è che noi
dobbiamo pure uscire mazza che bella
figura che mi stai facendo male poi
l'acqua distruggerà questa finestra e
guglielmo morire annegato a casa io ti
sta disegnando in questo momento il
macbook che non è carino che sei dai con
lo zuccotto te in confronto a quella
polpetta di arrivo oddio ma a guglielmo
del povero herbie denutrito e mette
sotto la pioggia
marello uccidere ok no e da una delle
pulizie
io devo fare cosa la città di
riaccompagnare a casa deve coincidere
dopo dopo si incerto samantha è se
portava una camera che il blog fanno
regali
andiamo ce la prendiamo noi ragazzi
escono rimasto sulla casa visto che loro
ieri hanno fatto scherzetti e cose così
in più a loro di rocchi giro il blog mas
alta non ci vedo niente alieno dalla
cioè la siamo nella merda gioca ma tocca
loggati vi dico subito che il mio natale
è partito malissimo e non impicchiamoci
qualcosa destra ecco ti prego perché
siamo per me c'è da sperare opportuno
che luigi nello neanche il tempo di
arrivare ad e quando ho bisogno di
energia ma c'è un po per me sono questo
mezzo wazzan dietetico dietetici simo il
ricco di fibre però e civilmente se avrà
un bel della è come se avessi fatto un
pranzo leggero equilibri si meno 3 e più
3 io per esempio pure sto a zero perché
il sonno nutella e cucchiaio che non sei
finita tutta domenico era già finita con
i nutella di skins si sa i biscotti
tutta salute ella dai wihelm manco ci
riesco a fare la mia porzione ammazza
che vacca 6
di carino che facciamo qualcosa tipo
vecchi film mezzo quello di berlino
natalizie i vari di quelli che sappiamo
a memoria tipo greenshoe doppiano un
film ritocchiamo un film natalizio tipo
che inventiamo una trama così si ci
rendono anche da casa rimane la grecia
insomma perché faccio la bambina però
faccio con una voce non mangiavano mamma
mamma mia
ho visto zombies con più dignità non so
di che parli
siamo stati 66 il coraggio dimostrati a
scusa non avessi messo in fallo non
sappiamo tutti che sei stato tu a
telecamere spente senso etico sono stati
19 contro la sono fatta di mondo e ne
passa zuppa questo vecchio che ci metta
un po che ma c'è un po di mira non mi
sentivo questo ok facciamo prudenza
senti quanto pesa questa leva b
mi serve una gru adesso ti metto nel
forno sai quanto è buona quella che già
vediamo un po metto un po di spezie
ecco qua sei stato fortunato
come ti cucino vediamo vediamo
un altro allora come valido
sono stanco di vedere io non volevo
mangiare la sua fidanzata e ha da sempre
una puntata di mika limite
lui è troppo magro per queste mie
trappole la nazione pandoro va fatta che
cosa ti hanno fatto mettere in testa i
tuoi genitori si è venuta qui per farmi
la ceretta
sappi che operi ovunque anche nel buco
di bacio teodem
io non voglio passare il natale in
questo posto di merda col buco
concetti di merda
senti ragazzo to passerà il natale col
nome con si è capito e indosserai quel
maglione di merda che lo stesso tutti
gli anni e sarei grato ne parlo
ha fatto un secondo io non lo farò mai
bossi che lo farai e mangerai accanto al
nonno lì accanto al nonno e la zia e il
tuo piatto sarà apprezzato da tappezzato
da sputi no sarei grato mi ringrazierai
di mangiare quella posizione
se non mangerai al bagno
parla troppo a proposito il barbecue ci
pensi turate monello bellissimo spazi
perché qui si chiudono le porte
adesso chiediamo la situation canvas
quest'anno io faccio babbo natale e tu
fai la befana
erano questi i patti ricordi mio beffa
come twitter oppure i poteri chiude le
porte mai domo notare sceglierò al
camino e un passo dalle porte mai ma la
fifa aveva sei pronto a fare la pepa nel
6 il milione naso da babbo natale
tu celebre farlo passando da vi fregano
il cavo lan o no non voglio non voglio
organizzare di capodanno ma ti prego da
facciamo che andiamo direttamente al 2
gennaio vi prego vi prego amore o dovrà
organizzare look il capodanno ecc
accurato dei sordi muovano prende i
soldi un pezzo tuoi brizzi non è vero
ladro in questo momento magari potrei
aver usato i soldi out per mangiarseli
in francia diva capodanno questo ci è
arrivato un dico io
sì è vero bonino prima forse ma al
contrario potremmo fare ognuno a casa
sua cioè to me dato un pacchetto da
bucaro
mi aspettavo qualcosa di meglio io non
so aspetta che passa telecamete tra
l'albero e bellocco l'ebit russa ecco i
muscoli ha capito tutti i sacchi ai
riciclatori chiaro ma ho questo dice una
parola
questo caso era una cafonata arida melo
su pc o associati sci club
lasciami stare lasciate stato riporta a
me lo fate riciclati se faccio un tempo
arriva al negozio prima che chiude 3
mila euro
dopo pure te di tanto su pieno che
cafonata ma che mi vedi sotto gli occhi
di hg pure stronza tutto mi sarei
aspettato ma che merici classi il regalo
dell'altr'anno no quello no non so
[ __ ] che ci ho scritto giocondo tu
vai tu madre terra porta to sorella che
odia guarda ma mantovani la crisi
guarda che cazzo fai proprio lavoro la
faccia ma che doma conte ok è carino no
bene per carino che compra una smartbox
ci senti so 3.000 euro per te per questi
tuoi mesi passati insieme e sta corre
troppo mi è qua adesso ma dai no col
cavolo è scappato di nuovo forse mai
capito ciò li vale tutti
ma pensavo che anello potesse essere la
chiave all'accesso capito intendo per
ragazzi seriate
alla fine di questa
[Musica]
ringrazio gaga grazie non mi sento stand
bagno sempre piaciuto questo video
commentate scrivendo bella swan
se no non è piaciuto niente non si può
parlare con questo che tossisce non ti
sopporto
se invece non vi è piaciuto commentate
pool chara da qualche mese è che
tossisce basta ragazzi sono molto stanco
quando sono nervoso e nervose spot
ciao se ancora stanco a questo
[Musica]
la linea è la linea di tiro sono e vela
lottato con la vigna in una maniera
assurda strapazzare ma ho fatto tutto
tutto cosa che non vi voglio di
proporzioni un pezzo karma rischia di
non essere una cosa nata scozia soft a
bravissimo per questo interrogativo che
chiudiamo una seconda volta